des panneaux pour indiquer que les
plages sont ouvertes mais que le coc vie
19 circule toujours
chaque jour de 6 heures à 19 heures le
bassin d'arcachon en gironde peut de
nouveau accueillir les visiteurs après
des semaines de fermeture
un soulagement pour les restaurateurs et
les hôteliers
il espère voir affluer des clients dès
le 2 juin date envisagée par le
gouvernement pour la réouverture des
établissements au public
on a dix personnes au chômage partiel
les permanents et tous les saisonniers
n'ont pas été employés pour l'instant on
a accueilli hier avec joie les mesures
de réouverture et on va maintenant dès
aujourd'hui royal est en train de se
remettre au travail pour demander
comment est-ce qu'on va organiser tout
ça est calé les besoins en termes
d'effectifs et prévisions de saison
qu'on pourra faire et la saison de cet
hôtel dépendra beaucoup des parisiens et
des lyonnais qui constituent l'essentiel
du contingent estivale les hôteliers
espère que les touristes français
écouteront les recommandations du
gouvernement qui appelle à réserver dans
les frontières de l'hexagone
un appel lancé en marge du plan marshall
pour le tourisme annoncé jeudi par le
premier ministre edouard philippe
chômage partiel report des charges prêts
garantis par l'état des mesures
importantes mais qui ne suffisent pas à
rassurer le président du bassin club
d'arcachon
on manque encore d'allègement un peu
plus important pour pouvoir sauver la
grande majorité parce que je pense que
ça va être compliqué et on se rend pas
bien compte que l'on va peut-être nous
sauver pour la saison mais dans les deux
ans à venir la crise économique va en
mettre un peu plus sur le carreau donc
leur nom
on en attend un petit peu plus si on
veut renégocier un petit peu plus
arcachon et dans ses environs les
professionnels du tourisme tente de
sauver les meubles
même s'ils savent qu'il sera impossible
d'attirer les 550 mille personnes qui
avaient visité le bassin pendant l'été
2010 9